[Music]
Sharon you and I know all about royal
weddings because we covered william and
kate's together what a great job we did
we had a great but can we go back to
Harry and Megan's wedding for a second
she turned fashion heads once again
while out on official palace business
with her man Prince Harry she's got such
a great sense of fashion I adore her and
it's up first in tonight royal report
all eyes were on the bride-to-be megan
wore a combination of pieces showcasing
her American heritage and designers from
the British Commonwealth her sleeveless
pinstripe trench style dress was from
New York designer Alta Zara the Blazer
casually draped over her shoulders is
from the Australian label Camilla and
Mark those strappy stiletto heels are
from Tamara Mellon who is British and
her crossbody bag is by the Australian
company oriT on mega choice of designers
has given an economic boost to the
fashion industry by putting a bright
spotlight on lesser known brands many of
the items she has worn have sold out she
and Harry attended the Commonwealth
Heads of Government Meeting Megan is
completely shaking up the monarchy by
assuming official royal duties before
she even ties the knot back when Kate
got engaged to William she wasn't given
any official roles before her marriage
will the royal couple honeymoon in
Africa there are rumors that the two
will be headed to the country of Namibia
both Harry and Megan love Africa and
Namibia is where Brad and Angelina chose
as the birth place for their daughter
Shiloh the two are eager to start a
family after they tie the knot on May 19
soon afterwards the obsession just might
turn to royal baby watch
well the clock's ticking for the family
I mean Prince Harry's made perfectly
clear that he wants to have a family he
wants to start soon he wants to catch it
with his brother I'm sure they're great
rivals and Megan is 37 in August so do
the math how long till Megan Marco gets
break one year one year yeah see I was
gonna say one day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]